اسمي اهالي الضحايا المفجوعين على ابنائهم
قاد المحقق العدلي طارق البيطار حربه
القضائيه
[موسيقى]
لكن الرد اتى مدويا من مدعي عام التمييز
غسان عويدات بالافراج عن موقفين مده عليهم
في قضيه انفجار مرفق بيروت
قرار اصابه شادي بجرح لا يقل الما عن
الشعر به عندما راى شقيقه مرميا في الرابع
من اغسطس
ليفجع اليوم مره ثانيه مترحما على قضاء
غدر بقدرهم كما يقول
مره ثانيه انا كنت اساسي في عندي امل
بالدوله اللبنانيه بس طلع ما في امل لا
الدوله اللبنانيه ولا بالقضاء القضاء طلع
اهل الشهداء والقضاء علينا ولا عدل ولا
عداله فيها هذه البلد انا بطلب من القاضي
عويدات يرجع ضميره
يرجع ضميره احنا متنا اخواتنا
عم تخلي سبيل موقوفين هي حرب القضاء اذا
لا يحبذها اهل القانون لكن خارج القضبان
هو مدير عام الجمارك السابق الذي قاد
التيار الوطني الحر حمله شرسه لاطلاقه اما
من افرج عنه فهو غسان عويدات القاضي الذي
كفت يده عن القضيه بسبب علاقه المصاهره
التي تربطه
نائب حركه امل الذي شن الثنائي الشيعي
حربا لمنع موسوله امام القاضي البيطار
صلاحيته
هلا بالنص
بيعرف
بس ولكن
يحاول الاهالي تنظيم تحركاتهم التي لم
تستثني الشارع كسبيلا للتعبير عن غضبهم
قدم انفجار بيروت على اكثر من 200 ضحيه
لبنانيه اما قرار القضاء بالافراج عن
الموقوفين فقضى على قلوب اهالا كانت تعيش
على امل تحقيق العداله غنوه يتيم العربيه
بيروت